- All right, Guemmy.
So as, as long as I can
remember on the internet,
you know, there's always
been, you create passwords,
and I feel like every
year they're asking me
to create more and more hard
or more difficult to remember passwords.
Why is this happening?
And and why is just the password
creation process so important?
- Yeah, so basically
your password is really
that key to the front door of your house.
And we have to make sure
that your password is unique,
and it's also very strong.
As you can imagine, if
you use the same key
across all of the houses in the universe,
then everybody would have that key
and they can get into your house as well.
And so it is really important to make sure
that not only that you
have a strong password,
but for all of those accounts
that you do care about
each of them are
different from each other.
- Right.
And there's certain accounts that,
I mean it is a good
model. I do this, okay.
If someone were to get
access to this account,
how bad is it?
My banking account, my social media,
those are pretty important.
So I wanna make sure I have
super strong passwords there.
Well, if it's something
that's a little bit
more frivolous or something,
and it's not the end of the
world someone has access,
right now you always see these rules
you know, at least this many characters
a number, a letter, uppercase, lowercase.
Why do we keep getting
all these constraints
being put on our passwords?
- Well, the whole point of
it is to make the password
as hard to guess as possible.
So you don't wanna, you
know, use common words
or things that can get easily guessed.
And it's actually very common for users
to use their names or their
pet names or birthdays.
These are things that
attackers can also guess
and will try to get into
your accounts as well.
That being said,
the way that we keep safe online
I think the advice has
changed over the years.
And so it actually you
don't actually have to
change your password that often
as long as you know that
there hasn't been a compromise
and that you do have a strong password.
And it's also okay to
like write your password
even on a post-it if you like.
But sometimes just being practical
is the best way to encourage people
to actually have these stronger passwords
that they actually can
remember and keep up with.
- That's super helpful.